- All right, we have one last story
I hope will give you all the feels.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Moving into a new neighborhood
can be a bit unnerving,
and that's how one Rhode Island mom felt
whenever she and her
family got their new house.
That is until the man
next door walked over
and introduced himself.
Almost instantly he became
a new member of the family,
as they say, an honorary grandpa.
We have Sharaine on the line right now
along with her daughter, Wilson,
and their neighbor,
Paul, watching on NBC 10.
Oh my gosh.
(audience cheers)
Okay, I'm gonna lead with you, Sharaine,
more on how did y'all meet?
Like he just walked over randomly?
- So, we just bought
our first home last year
and Paul came over to introduce himself
and asked my husband if he
needed to borrow a ladder.
The rest was history.
Ever since then, Paul has
been over for birthdays,
holidays, cookouts, Paul's there.
- I love it.
Well, Paul, you like to
entertain kids, right?
- Yep.
Kids say the darnedest things.
- Oh. (laughs)
Yeah.
- They have no rules or regulations.
They just say whatever there is.
- They really do say
whatever is in their mind.
Just ask my son anytime I exit my house.
He's like, "Oh, you're wearing that?
"That's a choice."
(audience laughs)
I'm like, okay, that's really fun.
But Wilson, what's one
of your favorite things
about having Paul as a neighbor?
- I like when he brings over some snacks,
and I like when he has fun with us
and I like when he takes his teeth out.
- Oh my God, Wilson,
you have my whole heart.
You are so adorable.
Oh my gosh, it was so
lovely to meet all of you.
Thank you so much,
Sharaine, Paul, and Wilson.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Sharaine] Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the Go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly good
neighbors, just like all y'all.
So, they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
That's 500 for Sharaine and 500 for Paul.
There you go!
(audience clapping)
- Oh my god, thank you.
- All right, thank y'all so much.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jacob Elordi, Jose Andres,
Elias, Audrey, and Lauren Cerand.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.